alors contrairement à ce qui avait été
annoncé on avait dit c'était un tournage
qui est reculée ben finalement fait
partie donc c'était de la semaine
dernière où ce dimanche dernier je crois
ouais les mecs vous deviez partie si
vous avez été annoncé sera comme étant
participants et que s'est il passé alors
nous ont contactés très tôt pour faire
les mutineries on s'est mis d'accord
avec la chaîne et la télé on me
proposait d'ailleurs financièrement je
crois que c'est une base autour de 20000
euros et me semble un briquet - rick
hendrick
la vérité c'est un badge autour de 20000
euros la facture en facture donc c'est
pas quelque chose de forcément c'est
comme un énorme et support pour accoter
que lorsqu'on a une nette embellie n'est
pas fait ça peut être compliqué alors je
l'ait pas fait parce que je veux la
vérité un papa n'est pas une réponse au
bidon non parce que je suis aujourd'hui
ici pour vous présenter le lancement des
ans j'étais à miami la semaine dernière
je suis rentré lundi ils ont décollé
dimanche
donc c'était compliqué pour moi et on
l'a décidé dans les prochains jours mes
amis afrique du sud s'est pas trop bien
non plus ouais ouais mais c'était
compliqué pour moi de faire les deux au
départ il y avait un planning initial
qui nous correspondait au temps assez f1
qu'à moi et puis finalement ça pas pu le
faire et moi je suis obligé de
privilégier mon groupe
est-ce que c'est pas plutôt pour une
question d'image honnêtement arrêtons de
nous mentir deux secondes je vous dire
confiance pour ce que je pense c'est sûr
mais beaucoup du cynisme ce prêt vous
l'auriez fait que ça a été une belle
bêtise parce qu'on avait réussi à faire
le tour dans la vie aussi de la
télé-réalité retourner dans cette
émission même si bon on verra ce que ça
va donner on va pas juger avant on va
attendre de voir
mais c'était quelque part faire marche
arrière et pour vous alors qu'il ya un
vrai succès en radio animateur ça va mal
j'ai vu tous les jours devant les
plateaux d'émissions de dimanche à 21h
est plutôt bien ce faisant ces gentilles
et s'arrêter pour moi et pour beaucoup
ici alors une erreur beaucoup viennent
m'a dit que ça aurait été une bêtise
alors en pesant tous ensemble le
planning 7
non mais aymeric faut arrêter je vous
aime beaucoup et je vous connais un
petit peu
vous avez vu le casting c'est un
naufrage vous êtes dit je vais pas être
embrigadé là dedans et chaponost plus
vite
vous avez une carrière à construire
beaucoup de seulement une carrière
derrière ou non non jamais c'est un tout
petit je suis un peu une carrière
derrière lui non mais c'est une émission
qui s'abrite derrière soi que pas de
carrière
voilà bientôt être un has been qu'un
never been
oui alors là franchement moi je voulais
être le bout du cast et c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas mal à être a émergé à a
commencé une carrière qu'on n'est pas il
n'y a pas beaucoup moins de moyens comme
moi je suis pas très connue encore plus
que cela bah non pas que je suis bon
niveau attendu de parenthèse on verra ce
que le programme est super et la
caractère associatif on va défendre une
association sur place
mais je suis pas de calais n'est pas
plus mauvais que à l'origine mais ben
jawad et je trouve que le concept déjà
moi me dérange
il m'avait déranger à l'époque qui me
dérange toujours alors en fait en poule
ce le fait d'avoir un casting qui est
aussi pourri j'ai dit et j'ai dit que
cette émission
ce serait vraiment une erreur que tu n'y
as y est c'est la meilleure décision que
j'ai prise de ta vie rennes rhume patois
normand cette mauvaise sincère parce que
les gens ne sont pas qu'une question de
carrière
est-ce que tu as derrière ou devant
c'est une question de dynamique dans la
dynamique elle est comme ça n'a aucune
raison d'annoncer des marches arrières
pensées machination oui allez-y alors si
christophe thébaud parler parce que je
voudrais saluer comme il m'aime ridge
récents voire en suis pas d'accord il ya
la question de l'image on va pas se
mentir
à partir de combien vous y allez quand
même vous a proposé 20 millions vous
proposer 50 mille voire 80 me alors je
vais vous dire la loire je vous dis n'a
jamais rien fait pour la russie et je
vais vous dire autre chose j'ai premier
une association qui s'appelle
l'association à la ddt pour les enfants
du mali que vous pouvez contacter de les
aider à travers cette émission j'ai pas
pu faire les missions et personnellement
j'ai financé l'école que je souhaitais
financière bravo
[Applaudissements]